but first we want to get to today's
headlines Charlie Demar has those from
the broadcast center right here in New
York City
good morning we begin with breaking news
from the Vatican which announced that
Pope Emeritus Benedict XVI has died he
was 95 years old Benedict Was the
right-hand man to Pope John Paul II
before he was elected to replace him in
2005. eight years later benedict made
history when he stepped down from a
position other popes had held until they
died Chris livesay is in Rome with the
latest Chris good morning
good morning Charlie the news comes
after Pope Francis asked for prayers for
his predecessor on Wednesday after
referring to Pope Benedict as quote very
sick and ever since then the Vatican has
been saying that the former Pope was
lucid and alert until this morning when
it announced that he had died in the
same Vatican Monastery he's called home
since he stepped down
nothing to find Benedict xvi's
pontificate so clearly as its ending
with his Majestic farewell flight over
the Eternal City Benedict had become the
first pope in 600 years to resign
he said his mental and physical strength
had deteriorated to the point that he
had to quote recognize my incapacity to
fulfill the ministry entrusted to me
he became Pope at age 78 born Joseph
ratzinger in a small German Town in 1927
he was forced to join the Hitler Youth
at age 14 and in 1943 was conscripted
into an anti-aircraft unit in the German
Army he deserted and was taken prisoner
by The Americans
he entered the priesthood after the war
Rose to become a cardinal and earned the
nickname God's Rottweiler as a rigid
enforcer of church policy critics hid
out at his slow response to the Decades
of cover-up of the scandal of sexual
abuse by priests and then came the
scandal of leaked documents that
disclose corruption and mismanagement in
the Vatican still he initiated some of
the changes the next Pope Francis would
later get credit for he began the reform
of Vatican finances and was the first
pope to meet with victims of sex abuse
and to publicly apologize condemning
what he called filth in the church
when he was 94 a new Scandal would
threaten his legacy accusations of
misconduct and his handling of sex abuse
cases more than four decades earlier
when he was Archbishop of Munich
Benedict's lawyers denied any cover-up
and Benedict asked for forgiveness a
scholar who had wanted nothing more than
to hide in Academia benedict made an
indelible mark on the church and history
when he became the pope who decided it
was time to go
now because Benedict was not a sitting
Pope what happens next is unprecedented
in modern times however we do know that
his body will lie in state here in Saint
Peter's Basilica starting on Monday and
on Thursday his funeral will be presided
over by Pope Francis Charlie Chris thank
you